with the extraordinary security measures
being taken in washington and across the
country ahead of wednesday's
inauguration
with the potential threat of more
violence this weekend businesses are
boarding up the national mall is shut
down and the pentagon has called up some
25
000 troops fencing in a stepped-up
security presence is also assembling at
state
capitals across the country the fbi has
warned of possible armed protests at all
50
state capitals federal prosecutors have
identified nearly 300 suspects in
connection with the january
sixth attack in washington with about
one third of that group facing
federal charges at this time this as new
details come to light about just how
close a violent mob got to vice
president mike pence
during that deadly siege on the capitol
congressional correspondent nicole
killian begins our coverage
at the white house this morning nicole
congratulations on your new position
what's happening there
well thanks jeff and good morning
everyone the mob reportedly
got within steps of where vice president
mike pence and his family were hiding
before an officer steered them away
washington drawing comparisons to a war
zone
walled off with barbed wire barricades
and blockades of national guard troops
at the ready
[Applause]
as disturbing new details emerge about
the january 6th insurrection
when riders stormed the capitol
protesters are in the building
vice president mike pence waited nearly
14 minutes in the senate
chamber after the initial security
breach giving the angry intruders time
to get closer to his location
some calling him a traitor and chanting
for him to be hanged
[Applause]
the rioters were less than 100 feet from
where the vice president
and his family were hiding before the
secret service evacuated them to safety
in court filings late this week
investigators say jacob
chansley dubbed the q anon shaman
espoused identifying and hanging leaders
he viewed as traitors within the united
states government
and that chansley left a note for mr
pence on the senate dais
it's only a matter of time justice is
coming
on friday dc's acting u.s attorney
michael sherwin said there is no direct
evidence teams of rioters were looking
to capture or
kill during the assault but
investigations are ongoing
that is a tier one top priority for both
the u.s attorney's office and our
federal law enforcement partners to see
again whether there was this overarching
command and control and whether there
were these
organized teams that were organized to
breach the capital
and then perhaps try to accomplish some
type of a mission
inside the capitol the capitol police
also opened a probe into whether some
members of congress helped the
protesters plan their assault
house speaker nancy pelosi named retired
lieutenant general russell honore
who led the military response to
hurricane katrina
to conduct an immediate review there was
strong interest in the congress
and the 9 11 type commission an outside
outside commission
to conduct that after action review
in the meantime i'm very grateful for
general honore
the washington post reports that an
internal
capitol police intelligence report
warned of a potential
violent scenario where congress itself
could be targeted
by some of the president's supporters
that red flag went out
three days before the riot but was not
widely shared with law enforcement so
far
no response from capitol police
thank you the more we learn it seems
like the more questions we have